la condena de 10 años de cárcel en
contra de la ex presidenta interina de
bolivia jeanine áñez ha generado una ola
de reacciones en bolivia la oposición
por ejemplo ha calificado el fallo como
un linchamiento judicial y un crimen
político en contra de la ex mandataria
pues considera que en el país no hubo
ningún golpe de estado sino un
levantamiento popular en cambio el
gobierno de luisa se ha calificado el
fallo como histórico para que no se
vuelvan a cometer supuestos golpes de
estado en el futuro el ex presidente
carlos mesa y líder del principal
partido de oposición ha señalado que
este es el peor crimen político que se
ha cometido en la historia de bolivia y
que daña la democracia entre tanto el
gobernador de santa cruz luis fernando
camacho quien ha encabezado las
protestas de 2019 que llevaron a años a
la presidencia ha señalado que la
sentencia es una muestra de que hay un
sometimiento de la justicia al
movimiento al socialismo el principal
partido de gobierno por otro lado hay
que señalar que la familia de la
expresidenta yanine años ha señalado que
va a recurrir a tribunales
internacionales
es para hacer valer los derechos de la
ex presidenta pues considera que en
bolivia no existe justicia entre tanto
del lado del gobierno el ministerio de
justicia y el ministerio de gobierno ha
indicado que el fallo es histórico la
ministra de la presidencia ha señalado
sin embargo que esperaban una condena
mucho más dura y por eso ha anunciado
que procederán a apelar este fallo la
principal víctima del supuesto delito de
jeanine áñez es evo morales el
expresidente que ha renunciado a su
cargo en 2019 y él también se ha
pronunciado señalando que se trata de
una sentencia benigna aunque también la
ha destacado hay que recordar que ya ni
de años ha sido sentenciada por los
actos cometidos durante los dos días
previos a la asunción al mando cuando
según la fiscalía los jueces y también
según el gobierno se ha tramado el golpe
de estado en contra de evo morales